very difficult technique
Roger and that's one of your
favorites this one here go has to go
under
his goes be behind his cheek
but the other one is this no you do s I
want this it's that one your arm is
elbows coming up oh and I'm hanging on
it oh right so you know Coke do are
where you go like that that's you got to
keep on the inside of his
arm that's a very difficult T technique
tension AG
is did you did you make the um J I've
forgotten that there was many people did
you make the 50e celebration could it's
going to cost so much money ah it's just
that there's a c I've got a cap for you
a little wooden cup that they they um
they give everybody a sacki cup all
right so I bought one for you so if you
I I'll tell Nigel it's for you oh hey
you s that's
right one of them cops is for
um per Allen per I don't know where they
are oh perhaps perhaps he's hid them um
I'll ask
[Music]
lence we got gradings and we got weapons
Scrolls and te well I don't know if you
um uh here just across that just across
that stamp there this yeah it's just
your signature in there cuz this is for
um ah Dominique yeah oh yeah oh well
done yes um I haven't marked do it has
it help to to or that no you're P
them Jane always says she reckons that
does better than half the strong stuff
they give
her
[Music]
you
which
[Music]
yeah oh
I
on this is
uh that's right this this is um in my
book in my book it says don't go
backwards to go forwards okay so what
you're doing is you're going this way
and then expecting him to go that way
but you you've added his
Mass to
you so you've either got to
go without bringing
him but without going backward yeah
thank
you
uh manual
manual try to try no like I said before
with my if you know look everything
everything's sort of
moving I mean everything's moving it's
got that gel to it it doesn't just go
here and then like a mechanical bit
there so you know I mean this all stops
and that and I do that yeah so so make
the whole
thing see what I
mean so it's a see see what's nice is
like you've got this this
feeling but if you just inside pretend
if you do this but inside and then you
go
yep all right so so you don't I always
say don't go don't go here if I'm next
going to come back here cuz I was
already there yeah so it it cuts out it
cuts out this movement cuz then if I do
that then I it would be better just to
do that
yeah
yeah that's it yeah you had it on the
back of
that too much too
much
[Music]
okay that's good let's have a look at um
miror again and John
okay
so two fifth
downs but they haven't met
before all right so because they haven't
met before they two normal human beings
will say right so if you just show the
technique and John's attacking so John's
attacking that's it and then you was
doing it with one
hand so I'm going to ask John a question
now and he's known me long enough to
give me a straight answer do you
actually know what he wants no
no and I can I know that
that but perhaps this person coming
we'll just say from another organization
like dominant that he might think this
guy is being awkward he's being
difficult on a fifth down and the people
I normally train with you know they they
go easy for me so this means
that without being too rude this you're
living a lie because it's not working
because you don't know that he's doing
tell me what you want and I'll do it
what I mean so that's why I particularly
chose look it sounds like I'm always
selling but we got different people here
from different stars of iido as far as
I'm concerned if your arido works it
works it don't matter what startle I
don't care you don't have to follow iaru
but but it's not working on you on
you so the the one thing about uh my in
my book I say don't go backwards to go
forwards so anytime that you any time
that you you come here you come here and
then you come back again if you go back
to a place that you've already been
you're going backwards to go forward so
why did you do that oh well it was to
get him going and I go well but that's a
waste you know we're getting older every
step I take I have to think about
nowadays you know I got bad KN so so our
whole concept of O senses iido is
minimalistic do as little as possible
but execute it
precisely
so if I want him to go down there I've
got to keep going until he goes down
there but we'd all get we see see the
Russians taught me this when I went to
Russia you got young guys really strong
they're there to you know prove sense
he's not as good as he thinks he is so
you got to deal with
everybody you don't know whether they're
fifth dance third dance first cues cuz
they wear hackimer from about you know
yellow Bel so you only the next day I
saw these bandages around these Uki
wrists and I'm going what they go up to
last night they're all injured and they
go it's you Sensei I go what do you mean
it's me and I go they should be to take
Nikos and S as they go They're not black
belts you know of course they didn't
know cuz they wear a white belt with a
hackimer so the techniques have to work
let's have a look at one let's have a
look at um I'll choose one let's have a
look at Nikko
here I come here
now a lower grade you would go back to
go forwards you'd come back here and
you'd then bow at
them because you're trying to learn it
mechanically so that's a sort of a
contradiction but what I'm doing is I'm
saying look please go past so I'm
getting out of his
way so my whole philosophy of please go
past is in motion here here now if
you're a q grade your nose will be
facing their
head if you're second down cuz I'm
jumping a bit I'll be facing you I'll be
missing his head if you're forc then
you'll be around
here so if you get here when you're
first down you're going to be and it
won't work so it it's like those
oldfashioned games where the ball
bearing falls into a little cup and then
you got to get the other bull bearings
in the cup it's a little bit like that
there's a place that your gut feeling
just goes that's
it you just know it's like it's there
you you have to do it slow until you
know that is definite because what will
go on most of your minds will be going
is it I don't know is it I don't know it
might be here see and that's what's
going on most of the time it might be
here so make yourself strong
hey but I'm in a six down place I should
be allow to do
that okay so what I do at my level now
hey is is I go inside the
person inside the person not not but
you've got to do it mechanically okay so
please try if